non seulement c'est plus cher d'envoyer
du pétrole par train mais c'est plus
dangereux
au canada le transport du pétrole par
train est souvent critiqué et apte à
croire responsable du transport pitre à
tout départ affirmé mme bishop du
produit que vous mettez dans vos wagon
son entreprise altex énergie est l'une
des seules à transporter du pétrole des
sables bitumineux à l'état brut
le produit tellement épais qu'il n'a
presque aucune chance de ce qui fait
augmenter les risques d'explosion s'il
diluant eau liquide très léger
combustible
on mélange ou bitume pour qu'ils coulent
facilement dans un pipe line with the
day one
mais au fond dans un train on n'en a pas
besoin sachant que le défaut principal
du transport par train c'est la sécurité
des gens le long des voies
donc si on le transporte non diluer le
pétrole devient presque inoffensif pour
l'instant environ 20% du bitume qui est
déplacé par rail au canada et non diluée
il ya d'autres entreprises canadiennes
qui pensent avoir trouvé une façon
encore plus sécuritaire de transporter
du pétrole albertain par train en
transportant sous forme solide
sacs en plastique blues se cache le
trésor de cale brodeur un projet sur
lequel il travaille depuis dix ans du
bitume en bleu sur lequel il peut tenir
debout et qui a cette consistance la
brodeuse souhaite envoyer ses premiers
blocs vers l'asie d'ici six mois dans
des conteneurs qui peut mettre sur des
trains et bateaux sonnent le gros
avantage avec un produit solide c'est
qu'en cas d'accident il ne coule pas
dans la nature au point d'arrivée les
blocs redeviennent liquide grâce à un
processus électrique
carbo 2 à développer il n'est pas le
seul à miser sur le pétrole solide cn
par exemple vient de lancer un projet
pilote d'un an pour transporter des
briquettes de bitume pareils
le lieu du clae moins cher que le train
pour du pétrole liquide diluée mais si
les solides pas besoin d'acheter de
diluant vous avez un produit très
concentré vous pouvez en mettre plus une
solution moins chère que le pipeline
une solution qui a quand même ses
limites ce n'est pas tout le pétrole qui
est transporté au canada qui peut être
solidifier celui issu des sables
bitumineux
oui mais celui qui a brûlé à
lac-mégantic qui venaient des états unis
était trop léger à la base pour être
transformés en bloc solide et puis les
oléoducs permet de transporter beaucoup
plus de pétrole
91 % de ce qui est exporté vers les
états unis est d'acheminer par pipeline
le train d'armes ces limitations
on peut faire passer un nombre fini de
wagons le pétrole non diluée ou
carrément solide ne va donc pas
transformer l'industrie demain matin
mais quand on sait que chaque jour des
wagons remplis de pétrole traverse des
communautés partout au pays
autant qu'ils le fassent de manière
sécuritaire
ici l'heure ans martin radio-canada à
l'iceberg en saskatchewan